et puis on retrouve tout de suite en
direct depuis à Kiev Gulliver crack
bonjour à vous Gulliver correspondante
France 24 dans la région de l'univers
une première question d'abord comment
est-ce qu'on a réagi dans la capitale
ukrainienne
alors vous voulez dire assez frappe sur
Moscou il y a la réaction du conseiller
développement
qui dit que l'Ukraine n'est pas
directement impliquée dans ses attaques
personne bien sûr dans le Kiev officiel
reconnaît une responsabilité plutôt ils
disent que c'est peut-être le travail
encore une fois de ces partisans russes
anti Poutine la légende de la Russie
libre par exemple ou encore selon
des des membres du Caucase de groupe
antiputine du Caucase la ligne de
l'Ukraine je pense va être toujours un
peu en rigolant de dire que tout cela
est lié à un conflit interne à la Russie
mais il ne cache pas le fait de se
réjouir en fait avoir ses drones ou ses
tentatives de drones sur Moscou et ses
alentours notamment sur une banlieue
huppée de Moscou né à la radio les
donneurs d'opinion sont un peu partagés
sur la question il se demande si
vraiment c'est la bonne stratégie pour
l'Ukraine et la bonne utilisation de ces
moyens si comme tout le monde semble le
penser l'Ukraine soutient et donne les
équipements à ces groupes russes qui
attaquent la Russie même si c'est
peut-être pas des Ukrainiens eux-mêmes
qui pilotent les drones et qui lancent
les attaques est-ce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va infléchir l'opinion
publique en Russie est-ce que ce ne
serait pas mieux d'utiliser ce genre
d'équipement pour attaquer des bases
militaires tout simplement ou des dépôts
de pétrole etc comme cela a été le cas
jusqu'à présent normalement sur des
sites un peu plus près de la frontière
avec l'Ukraine rouge je pense que
l'opinion est partagée en Ukraine mais
un dernier mot sur ces frappes sur
Moscou beaucoup de gens ici à Kiev il
voit la suite de une annonce qui avait
été fait hier par le patron des
renseignements militaires Ukrainiens qui
rient le bouddhaneuf qui avait dit les
Russes vont voir très vite notre
revanche revanche bien sûr pour cette
série d'attaque sur Kiev justement la
Russie accusée directement chef d'être à
l'origine de ces frappes les Russes il
voyait une riposte après les frappes
conduites par des drones sur la capitale
ukrainienne hier quelles sont les dégâts
que vous vous avez constaté sur place
alors je me trouve devant le bâtiment
qui a le plus souffert du moins de ce
que nous annonce publiquement c'est un
immeuble de appartement le drone aurait
été intercepté mais n'aurait pas fini
d'exploser visiblement avant de frapper
les étages supérieurs du bâtiment que
vous ne voyez pas mais qui sont très
serrement endommagés 12 appartements au
moins sont complètement détruits selon
les autorités je pense que vous voyez
les opérations de nettoyage sont en
cours en cours de temps à autre on
entend une fenêtre jetée ou d'autres
morceaux de prix à côté de moi il y a un
terrain de jeu d'enfants qui est couvert
de débrismes et qui servent maintenant
de bureau improvisés pour que les gens
réclament des compensations pour les
décaper leurs propriétés une personne
ici a trouvé la mort sur Kiev dans sa
totalité 13 personnes ont été blessées
mais ça c'est sur si districts qui ont
été frappés les autorités disent que 29
sur 31 drone ont été interceptés il se
peut que discip les militaires aient été
touchés sur une péninsule dans la
rivière dans le centre de Kiev puisque
l'accès à ces territoires et fermé et on
sait que les Russes avaient tenté de
frapper ce territoire à plusieurs
reprises avant mais publiquement il n'y
a pas d'information sur des
réussites sur des cibles militaires par
ces deux drones donc qui n'ont pas été
interceptés sur les 31 merci beaucoup
gilet merci pour ce compte-rendu depuis